[Music]  well enough about us if you're the one  add all the teeth [ __ ] over there tell  us  ain't got no cherry  yes you do know I don't know anything  that's going on with you and your  divorce I don't think this is gonna  happen because you love your husband  keep thinking you getting yeah don't ask  me so Tim I um yes are you getting a  plan so a thousand percent was it would  it didn't say when you told him you won  your divorce uh he said do you sure you  don't wanna go to counseling  no honey Vince obviously love each other  and I just think she don't want to talk  about it and I think she's choosing to  be tough about it which is I mean I get  it but it's not necessary with her  sisters  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]